Yeah,
got very,
very little to do with the construction
of the welfare state economic model.
That was one element of the economic
model that was fundamentally flawed.
We are the fixed exchange rate policy
and that was untenable.
We try to defend the fixed exchange rate
with interest rates up to 500 percent.
That was ridiculous.
It was a failure,
but we were so
indoctrinated.
We had lived with a fixed exchange rate
regime all our lives since the early
thirties and we could not imagine that
was something wrong with the fundamental
element of our economic policy.
When that was abolished,
the economy took off and we've had much
more flexible situation since then and
today.
It is one of the fundamental assets of
our economy that we are flexible enough
to set interest rates according to our
own needs,
high interest rates if you have
overheating innovation and can stimulate
by low interest rates when recession is
that threatening,
and I think that was one of the main
elements of the shocks that we
experienced in the late eighties.
We had a shock from the financial
markets and as you know,
financial markets destabilized.
They don't stabilize ID stabilize
economies,
the destabilized our economy,
we could not do anything about it
because we did not have in our
possession the interest rate weapon
because we had a fixed exchange rate
regime and I think that was a much more
important explanation.